[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
Mutombo
proud suppliers of premium jeans at a
fair price
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm and the Strausser Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to so why
is this a thing now don't get me wrong I
always enjoy 1995's a goofy movie fine
but somewhere in the past five or ten
years it's gone from that cute little
movie to Disney cult status garnering
fan art merchandise reenactments and too
many cosplays to count I stayed away
from reviewing this movie for a while
because I didn't really understand what
all the fuss was about but my
fascination over this fascination has
finally gotten the best of me what is it
about this film has left such an impact
on so many people well I'm finally gonna
take a closer look to find out let's
time travel back to the 90s with a goofy
movie the opening credits start off
standard enough almost Tuesday I'm not
gonna lie a part of me really wonders
with just a movie would be boy meets
girl nothing happens for two hours roll
credits I didn't say it'd be good but
it'd be a movie it starts off rather
beautiful with our main character max
dreaming about a girl he has a crush on
named Roxanne
[Music]
and to be fair this fantasy is kinder
than the fantasies the internet has had
about her
oh no he's turning into Disney's real
nightmare Oswald rabbits get over it
Disney you got him back in Epic Mickey I
don't know how you make Goofy's laugh
scary but you found a way it's all just
a dream though as Max answers his
landline in Joe telling his friend PJ to
get ready for the big day son his father
goofy of course embarrasses him every
moment possible but Mac says after today
he'll be the coolest kid on the block
[Music]
as catchy as this song is I have to ask
do all the dogs just live in one
neighborhood they're the only animals I
see in this town is there a class system
aren't they the Lion King hyenas evolved
two years later film theory that it
has to make more sense that how a bus
full of kids turns into a bus full of
cheerleaders and the back into a bus
full of kids if you film it while
complaining about movies you can make it
very good living that way sadly we
discovered this movies been infected by
a Polish or I was a thing he helps Max
and PJ set up a prank during the
school's last prep rally as wait a
minute this is the 90s cue the adult
authority figure who just doesn't
understand principal Mazur what can we
do to not waste our summer vacation like
never dealing with a Sicilian when death
is on the line
how about science slumber parties okay
my only one who wants to see that happen
what wouldn't deal deGrasse Tyson's
pajamas look like but they ambushed the
rally with max dressed as their favorite
pop star power line
[Music]
that should allow me but I'm just
wondering what it means when the dog
makes a dog sound remember would goofy
owned a cat is that slavery max also
takes the opportunity to hit on Roxanne
there's nothing that I wouldn't do you
know is it possible to make something so
David it's actually timeless this movie
is really trying to say yes he's finally
caught though resulting in him getting
detention max look
it's the Leaning Tower of Pisa he's not
in this lawn
Roxanne stumbles across max though in
the principal's office
I liked your dance yeah yeah oh yeah
it's from powerlines new video I know
he's he's totally genius yeah he's doing
a concert next week in LA oh yeah oh
it's puppy love it is nice that rocks
and isn't just uh play into popular
knockout
she's shy nervous has some geeky friends
and is just as awkward as max making for
honestly some adorable flirting sorry
it's okay really
I've never touched a nun gloved hand
before he gets a date with her though to
watch the powerline concert on TV as
goofy blissfully works his job as a baby
photographer each retina sleeping
tonight pause this movie when that kid's
eyes go red you're welcome
his coworker Pete tries to show off what
a much better parent he is with his son
for all you know he's running around
with some gang and stealing stuff and
causing riots something's wrong when a
kid won't spend time with his parents
just ask Norman Bates what goofy gets a
call about the trouble max is in why
this wordage is eerily similar to my
co-workers verbalization of my fears
because goofy cartoon should always
suggest that imagery goofy thinks he's
been too hard on max though so he
decides to take him on a fishing trip
ruining his date with Roxanne it's a
vacation with me and my best buddy Oh
Donald Duck no he's gone all angular and
weird I'm kind of afraid of him now
we're going fishing yup just like my bad
medias
we're using the same app man my dad used
yeah I don't see tippy dog's name on
that map google it you'll get a giggle
max convinces goofy to drop by Roxanne's
house though to tell her the bad news is
Roxanne
it's okay daddy Max is a friend from
school please call off your dad dog
afraid she might find someone else he
makes up a lie saying he's gonna be
onstage at the powerline concert because
his dad knows him personally of course
he has no idea how to make this possible
you think of a name and I'll try and
guess who it is my inner woman man Walt
Disney oh did we just implode our
universe for a minute though to try and
make max feel better goofy try singing a
little song there really doe break
brought modern Libba along to shed your
weary low weight Mickey Mouse is on a
phone yeah he still has to hitchhike and
he's with Donald who goofy said he's
really good friends with do max you
should ask maybe your dad does know
powerline these are some weird
connections
[Music]
okay has anyone put together how
potentially disturbing this song
sequences you have country singers
stuffed in a piano a hostage in the
trunk of a car and the dead literally
coming back to life this is a freaking
morbid interstate so they drop by a
possum children's attraction along the
way because apparently that exists in
this world too that's every kid that was
dropped off at the nut job yet another
creepy child in this movie can we just
keep the camera off them for the
remainder of the film little cagey film
you were this close to getting a P put
in front of you also why is anyone trust
like a giant animal they're all giant
animals there is no novelty
okay goofy movie surprisingly has a lot
of nightmare fuel
embarrass goofy tries to make max feel
better by showing him how to fish let me
show you a little family secret and 13
generations perfect what the perfect
cast
you know something Suicide Squad in
health but they come across big fight
yeah that happens this is kind of a
weird direction I surprisingly expected
a little less goofiness out of a goofy
movie they get trapped in the car as
bigfoot lists through their belongings I
[Music]
know I should be laughing but now I'm
just wondering what the BG's as dog
people look like Max and goofy start to
bond over making food though as goofy
reminds max of when he used to spell hi
dad in his alphabet soup you used to
spell things out using the letters like
ambidextrous words like by boy or I
pledge allegiance or I love you when you
realize this movie is kind of
working followed by
[Music]
maxie excuse me I got something in my
eye there we go
where was I oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you looking at my butt good how can you
not in these motton bow jeans they look
great are super comfortable and feel ten
times better than any other jeans I've
tried with plenty of styles for both men
and women it's so easy to get the
perfect pair especially with their home
Tryon program you can even send back the
pair you don't want in fact if you go to
their site you can not only see all the
other clothes that they have but also
see all the great reviews they got their
history and even the science of denim
they go into the science of why your
hands will look amazing god bless you
science of denim look at them but that's
a butt of the gods and you can get 20%
off your first purchase
just use the co-channel awesome at
checkout and you will get 20% off you
can have my butt in jean form go half my
butt in jean format motton Balcom use
the co-channel awesome at checkout to
save 20% great jeans creating great
prices creating great butts what's not
to add or offer expires October 31st
[Applause]
it starts to write Roxanne and meeting
you lie but then realizes he can change
the map to go to the concert because
every kid needs their first oh I get it
unaware the Matt's been altered they
both compromised and visit the places
the other wants to see
[Music]
oh you're a committed abstract murder
they end up at what I can only describe
as the Little Mermaid's Love Shack
no those fish got hysteric coupies junco
Knights are the fish people in this
world I need to know how to judge this
as Pete and PJ happen to be staying at
the exact same place Pete overhears
about max changing the map and decides
to tell goof I just hate to be the
bearer of bad news but well I heard the
little mutant telling PJ that he changed
the map so your head straight to LA pal
honest I know do we really not even take
off our gloves in the hot tub our world
is weird goofy funny enough this moment
gets surprisingly uncomfortable you know
even max hidden all the things that you
think his son should be but he loves me
hey my son respects me I'm starting to
think Pete's hiding an abusive family
story we're not aware of where did the
wife and daughter go goofy does check
the map though and realizes Pete was
right leading to a great scene where
goofy gives max a chance to redeem
himself by telling him the right
direction
left or right
[Music]
most Disney movies would have this be
the time where max does the right thing
but then make it a bit more interesting
by still having him lie after goofy gets
fed up in one of the few quiet moments
of the film they finally open up and
share their feelings in the most
cartoony way possible wishing they
talked about their feelings at the top
utilizing that quiet moment some more
but on the other hand talking about your
feelings while tumbling down a canyon
and driving through Rapids feels like
the way a goofy movie should handle they
blow up at each other and sit in silence
while yeah there's no other way to say
it they're in a car did you open up
slowly though via song really we should
be singing about how our car would have
drowned by now we should both be dead
but this is cool too speaking of death
max remembers the perfect cast though
when uses it to save his dad as a way to
say thanks for giving them that
situation in the first place
goofy helps max partake in breaking
entering and forgetting he has a serious
girlfriend for a minute goof even has a
little bit of a creeper moment too I
don't want to know the other times goofy
has made that face series of mess ups
both max and goofy make their way in
front of the crowd with power line who
of course just rolled with the dangerous
strangers who rushed the stage and
Britney Spears asked if her intruder had
a gun she should just dance to it so
everyone watching of course sees max and
goofy on TV
he's dancing with Prince debo Jackson
max returns home and tells Roxanne the
truth but she of course understands and
it leads to more adorkable chemistry you
want to do something tonight I'm kind of
doing some with my dad
honest how about tomorrow deal I wanna
bundle you booth up in a cute ball and
put you in a cute box of cute
goofy of course embarrasses him again
but this time max decides to roll with
it and just accept who he is
Roxanne I'd like you to meet my dad on
Shantay
Oh yo I killed a mine
and that was a goofy movie is it as good
as people have built it up over the
years honestly I will admit the more I
watch it the better it gets it's silly
of course best to be expected but it
also captures a lot of the excitement
insecurities and angers of being a teen
as well as being a parent their
disconnect is very believable and
neither side is necessarily wrong it's
an identifiable connection that allows
for a fair amount of laughs as well as a
fair amount of drama even the serious
moments from goofy from friggin goofy
are surprisingly kind of touching sure
it's a product of its times but it seems
dated in the right ways and it seems
timeless in the right ways making it
enjoyable retro but also sympathetically
heartfelt add in a touch of a cynical
edge beautifully flowing animation and
artistically pleasing backdrops and you
have a movie that tried a lot harder
than it needed to resulting in an
experience that's surprisingly still
pretty damn good
[Music]
I thought a Schnauzer credit guide
remember so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey this is dog walker doing the charity
shout-out once again we're not doing any
videos or pictures or music this time
because once again this is one that
sadly has happened very recently and you
only need to turn on the news to see
what's going on that's hurricane
Irma this one is from GlobalGiving and
everything that's put into it is given
to the communities Charity Navigator
says this is pretty much the best one to
give to I've been watching the news you
know all the terrible things have been
happening there and so many people are
left without homes and they just don't
deserve that and follow so quickly after
another hurricane after another tragic
event is just truly awful so definitely
click on the link below and see if you
have anything you can give because man
so many people are in trouble and they
just don't deserve to be definitely
definitely click on the link below even
the tiniest bit will help if we all come
together and we just give what we can we
can really make a huge difference right
now so please definitely click on the
link below and share what you can thank
you again
you